[la musique]
et sans aucune crainte
sautez du pont sur 200 mètres vous volez pendant des jours
comme un oiseau à l'envers tu sais comment
[la musique]
[applaudissements]
grand-mère d'été appelle-moi
chevauche les barres transversales locales le reste du temps
Traqué
[la musique]
J'ai fait ça cinq ans au milieu de 12
registres et inscrits dans le livre des registres
Russie
[la musique]
J'ai testé mon énergie sur quoi d'autre suis-je dans
ses quatre-vingt-dix-neuf ans est capable de
99 ans, je suis sur un réservoir d'élastique
[la musique]
Je l'ai même forcé quelques fois
boucle blanche et cette réponse est diabolique, c'est tout
fait le tonneau plusieurs fois
faire faire faire
J'ai des fils de 24 ans
maintenant si sur zil
[la musique]
à
Je fais toujours de bonnes actions pour les gens
tu comprends ici
J'aime même aider une personne
mon problème est une autre fois que tu y vas
l'homme à l'arrêt de bus va au bus je
J'arrête de prendre et laisse tomber sa mémoire
sans un pincement de conscience je ne prends pas
à court d'argent lièvre
[la musique]
novara litre d'huile vieille femme comment vivre
et se battre pour la vie
attention aux jeunes oiseaux
[la musique]